oulan bator capitale de la mongolie 8
heures du matin -10 degrés
[Musique]
comme chaque jour n'a rangers elle et
son fils ait nar quatre ans sortent du
trou qui leur sert de maison dans un
puit d'accès au réseau de chauffage
urbain envahi par la pourriture l'uriné
la boue pour aller gagner le péniblement
mille tout creed c'est à dire même pas 1
euro
allez on va vendre vos canettes
pour survivre ils fouillent
inlassablement les poubelles de la ville
à la recherche de vieilles bouteilles et
canettes qu'il va revendre au recyclage
où est la mère de l'enfant impossible de
le savoir
malgré un soleil trompeur le froid est
extrême il faudra bientôt moins 30
degrés et pendant sept mois c'est pour
échapper à une mort certaine que les
sans-domicile trouvent refuge dans les
entrailles surchauffée de la capitale
ici les gens jettent leurs déchets
récupèrent les restes de repas
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans la vie de
cet homme pour qu'il en soit réduit à
manger des détritus et avec son fils
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ce pays pour
qu'on laisse un enfant de 4 ans vivent
comme un clochard
j'étais professeur à l'académie
militaire mais j'ai eu un accident je me
suis retrouvé en invalidité sans amis et
sans travail
donne moi ta main
aussi mon fils tu porteras les poubelles
20 41 ramasse ce papier et veulent
mettre à la poubelle
j'ai deux autres enfants ils sont mariés
ils vivent chez leurs beaux-parents ce
jeu le rend pas visite je peux pas y
aller dans cet état
je suis très content qu'ils allaient
bien
mais j'ai honte de moi pourquoi vous
avez honte
parce que je suis pauvre
les gens viennent parler avec vous
non les gens ne viennent jamais discuté
avec moi comme ça
c'est la première fois
je te remercie
je viens du village de chengere dans
l'arc ngai
mon père était un très bon chanteur
habito
regarde mon fils c'est mon bien le plus
précieux
il me suis tout le temps on ne se sépare
jamais je les aime tellement
[Musique]
l'histoire de ce père et de ce fils
c'est celle de la mongolie d'aujourd'hui
des êtres perdus entre deux mondes
inadaptée à une nouvelle réalité
sacrifier à un capitalisme balbutiant
ils sont les victimes de la transition
depuis l'effondrement de l'empiré
soviétique
ils font la douloureuse apprentissage de
la liberté
[Musique]
avant de venir ici qu'est ce que je
savais de la mongolie un pays coincé
entre la russie la chine une destination
touristique des grands espaces et
cavaliers qui chasse avec des aigles le
désert de gobi gengis khan finalement
pas grand chose
un duc par exemple ne savais pas ce que
c'était cap sud va c'est une catastrophe
climatique rarissime un vent glacial qui
peut être moins 60 degrés et auquel le
bétail ne résiste pas il y en a eu deux
pratiquement coup sur coup cheptel
décimé ça veut dire plus rien à manger
plus d'argent
plus de soin plus de moyens de
locomotion plus d'écoles donc un exode
vers les villes et donc une catastrophe
humanitaire
des nomades ruinait et affamés
contraints de se replier avec leur
yourte temps de gigantesque bidonville
glace et les réfugiés
alors j'ai eu envie de raconter
l'histoire de ces victimes de ce peuple
qui perd pied mais qui luttent pour
tenter de préserver sa culture et son
identité à des premiers personnages que
je rencontre dans ce paysage de misère
qui ceinturent la ville et bayard byumba
ce qui signifie samedi de fête il est
venu donner un coup de main à ses
enfants
je suis éleveur j'ai laissé mes bêtes à
la campagne je suis venue des deux de
mes enfants et qui ont trouvé du travail
paris si
vous pensez que vous allez vous
installer ici
mes enfants mais moi non moi j'ai grandi
à la campagne
cette vie ne me convient pas et puis à
la pollution aussi la fumée c'est
horrible ça ça n'existe pas à la
campagne à nos côtés
[Musique]
dans ce passage brutal du moyen-âge à la
modernité et de la férule soviétique au
vertige démocratique lit à ollioules
shimell elle vient d'arriver en ville
avec son mari et sa fille
nous sommes arrivés les halles vingtaine
de jours je suis venu de la région de
bahia congo
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez quitté la
campagne
on est venu s'installer en ville car
toutes nos bêtes sont mortes de froid
cet hiver à cause du sud
comme yunxi mag chaque jour de nouveaux
habitants des plaines troquent leur vie
de nomades pour des bidonvilles d'une
capitale qui a le charme des barres hlm
beaucoup de ses anciens nomades qui
n'ont pas réussi à s'insérer en ville
survivre grâce aux ong étrangères
olivier est ici depuis un an et demi il
coordonne les programmes alimentaires
d'action contre la faim
le pays en transition je pense il ya
beaucoup de nos man qui se sédentariser
et c'est comment ce phénomène a l'air
assez rapide et il ya un problème
d'adaptation
de structures au niveau 2 de la ville et
aussi je pense que les gens doivent
recommencer un nouveau mode de vie quoi
en attendant il faut manger acf
contribue à fournir l'essentiel avec des
soupes populaires où se bousculent
chaque jour des centaines de gueules
cassées et des gamins solitaire
je viens souvent ici oui
où sont tes parents
je n'ai pas de faire j'habite avec ma
mère
elle est femme de ménage
avec ce que je gagne je peux à peine
acheté un sac de farine
avant je travaillais dans une centrale
électrique je picole et les produits de
nettoyage des cuves là bas aujourd'hui
je suis alcoolique et je ne peux plus
m'arrêter
en mongolie pauvreté égale alcoolisme un
alcoolisme radical qui fait tomber
encore plus bas ceux qui ont cherché un
refuge dans une vodka trafic et au
méthanol terriblement toxiques et qui ne
coûte pratiquement rien
les plus chanceux de ces
laissés-pour-compte échoue à l'hôpital
de la charité unique établissement
gratuit et qui est soutenu par acf
pauvres parmi les pauvres ils sont
ramassés dans la rue ou sous les
trottoirs de la ville inconscient
baignant dans un véritable bouillon de
culture où ils développent des maladies
infectieuses tuberculose le money
typhoïde hépatites
du foie
la vague 4 ans
il boit
[Musique]
tard
les entrailles de la capitale abrite
également des gamins en rupture fuyant
la violence d'un foyer ou bien
abandonnés par leurs parents
c'est dans les cryptes angoissante des
sous-sols qu'ils reconstituent leurs
familles d'adoption on les trouve dans
la rue livrés à eux mêmes
traînant en bande et incapable de se
projeter dans l'avenir ils sont des
proies faciles pour la police qui les
charge de tous les crimes pour les
proxénètes et pour les caïds du coin
[Musique]
ça fait onze ans que je vis dans la rue
c'est mon père qui m'a abandonnée à la
gare
moi j'ai 13 ans tu es ici depuis combien
de temps je me suis enfui de
l'orphelinat l'année dernière il
s'appelle bâtard moon couvent ou encore
batman qu ils ont entre 13 et 17 ans et
leur vie est si précaire qu'elle se
conjugue au présent
on ne mange pas trop si on trouve une
voiture à laver ça va sinon on mange pas
la police est là caïd du quartier nous
font la vie dure
quand on dort ils viennent pour nous
battre la police aussi ça fait peur
à chaque fois que quelqu'un se fait
voler à la station de bus c'est nous que
la police accuse c'est pas facile comme
vie mais on habitués
[Musique]
ici s'entassent les mômes qui vivent
dans une odeur de pourriture les
fameuses canalisation de l'eau à 130°
elles peuvent ou pire comme un steak
quand une fuite ne vous est bouillante
pendant la nuit on suffoque dans ce
refuge misérable de 6 mètres carrés sur
chauffer
en hiver ça va il fait chaud ici
c'est pas trop dur de vivre dans ces
conditions ça là
il ya des mouches pas des cafards
partout ici
vous voudriez aller à l'école tout petit
c'est la seule chose qu'on est sûr de ne
pas aimer
regarde ce qu'ils ont fait à la main de
bayard à
14 on dormait quelqu'un dit y'a
quelqu'un c'était la police ils nous ont
demandé de sortir et on est sorti
j'étais juste en débardeur moi j'ai eu
de la chance et m'ont laissée ils ont
tabassé mes deux amis ils ont beaucoup
pleuré
pourquoi la police vous tapez
c'est comme ça les freak touba toul sens
ils ont pris l'habitude
qu'est ce que tu as au bras
des cicatrices
comment tu t'es fait ça j'étais saoul
que à moins que ce ne soient les plus
désespérés prennent tous les risques
pour fuir une déchéance inéluctable
ancien berger dépossédés de leurs bêtes
par le froid ou bien ouvriers au chômage
il quitte la ville à pied et gagnent des
vallées éloignés ils parcourent parfois
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres il se
précipite vers le nouvel eldorado de la
misère les mines d'or ça fait rêver moi
aussi ça me fait rêver alors j'essaie
d'y aller personne ne semble savoir où
c'est parce que c'est illégal on me dit
que c'est dangereux que c'est violent
tant pis nous partons à la rencontre de
ceux que l'on appelle les ninjas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est plus intéressant de travail ici
khawlane bator
oui laure ça gagne un jet ski cross dans
le trou là une amie à moi
bien montre toi c'est ce qu'il y a
ladsous c'est dangereux oui bien sûr
quel genre de danger
ça peut s'effondrer oui ça peut
s'effondrer
et après on prend la terre et on va la
tamise et là bas à la rivière
on est loin de la sauvagerie qu'on
m'avait annoncé à oulan bator
ici personne ne nous menace de quoi que
ce soit sommes épuisés vieillards femmes
et enfants fouillent la terre en charrie
des tonnes sur leur dos brisé ce gel les
mains dans une eau glacée à la recherche
de quelques grammes de métal précieux
[Applaudissements]
mais combien on peut en trouver bah ça
dépend du sol de la personne qui cherche
aussi
quelques grammes par jour peut-être
c'est vraiment très difficile il fait
très froid ici l'eau est gelé
en plus on n'a pas d'engins mécaniques
pour creuser nous c'est tout à la main
avant j'arrivais à soulever un sac de
terre mais là je n'ai plus de force
j'ai mal aux jambes
certains de ceux qui se sont échoués ici
et puis ce depuis plusieurs années pour
faire vivre leur famille
comme si chic bâtard qui est là depuis
trois ans
j'ai deux enfants étudiants il faut bien
que je fasse quelque chose pour eux
je paye leurs études d'ici
c'est difficile pendant l'hiver mais
l'été ça va mieux
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé pour le moment
pour une journée c'est pas grand chose
difficile on fait tout à la main en plus
les uns des compagnies privées bloquent
les accès les meilleurs coins ils disent
que c'était eux
on est dans la vie d arrivée avec leur
machine et commence à creuser côté nous
c'est très dangereux et on n'arrête pas
de s'enlever la vie que
tout à coup nous étions tous les acteurs
d'un théâtre de l'absurde au bout du
monde d être couverts de poussière
épuisé par des travaux inhumain mais
debout face à eux des français sidéré
par une telle énergie du désespoir
a tabou
[Musique]
dans ce décor lunaire je ne voyais plus
la misère effacé par l'énergie de ces
gens qui continuait à espérer
qu'ils avaient foi en l'avenir comme ces
enfants insouciants qui jouait dans ce
no man's land
dans ce no man's land
c'était presque la fin du voyage et je
commence à me demander comment j'allais
le raconter j'avais croisé des gens qui
avaient tout perdu bétail emploi famille
bonheur mais jamais leur dignité
j'ai découvert un peuple d'une force
incroyable je ne pouvais pas partir de
ce pays sans rencontrer ceux qui s'en
était sorti il existait forcément
ce sont ceux que le vent glacé a poussé
vers la ville qui ont relevé la tête et
qui ont réussi à retourner dans les
steppes là où sont leurs racines comme
liam d'orge dont l'histoire raconte la
puissance de qui mord le cheval du vent
qui est pour les mongols symbole de
force et d'énergie vitale
avec le dj perdu 26 chevaux est
pratiquement une centaine de moutons les
chèvres je les ai vendu pour acheter de
l'essence pour ma moto dans l'espoir de
retrouver les bêtes égarées j'ai rien
retrouvé du tout qui complètement
déprimé j'avais perdu le sommeil faye
devenir fou
c'était très dur
les conditions étaient très difficiles à
supporter
surtout psychologiquement
on a été obligé de partir on avait plus
rien mes fils en garde et les deux
chevaux et nous on a marché jusqu'à la
ville mes deux chiens sont morts pendant
le voyage très dur vous savez de quitter
sa région natale puis faut pas croire
qu'en ville on a la belle vie
on a trouvé un boulot de gardien ont
gagné 50 mille kubrick ça a duré que
quelques mois le patron a donné le
travail à quelqu'un qui le connaît c'est
mieux de toute façon d'étouffer en ville
on n'a pas été habitué à vivre entre des
murs
ce n'est pas on avait envie de retourner
chez nous mais on ne sait pas comment
faire sans les bêtes et puis on s'est
décidé on s'est dit que
il y aurait toujours quelqu'un pour nous
donner un peu de yaourts et de la jument
vous savez même sans rien on est mieux
là où on est né parce qu'à la famille
les amis tout le monde se connaît
ils étaient contents de rentrer chez
nous on est arrivés en été quand nos
voisins nous ont vu revenir ils nous ont
demandé si on était venu prendre l'air
dans sa loge j'ai fais de beaux rêves
[Musique]
le souvenir que j'aurais voulu garder de
ce voyage c'est celui de ces nomades qui
ont réussi à retrouver leurs repères
leur identité leurs troupeaux
bon
[Musique]
au moment de partir je repensais à ces
regards que j'avais croisé pendant ces
12 jours en mongolie
à ces histoires d'hommes et de femmes
qui m'avait marqué
[Musique]
mais parmi toutes ces images qui se sont
gravés dans ma mémoire
celle qui va continuer à obséder
longtemps c'est celle qui raconte la vie
de ce père et de son fils
est ce que tu aimes tant
que maire interoute
ça me
la fracture se mena
c'est plus un homme
c'est criminel
tabou
c'est tout
c'est imminent
tu m'etonnes
c'est une langue
or soldats